[Music]  well you guys are reuniting tonight yes  first time I think we've all been  together since 95 I think wow it's crazy  it's really crazy actually to think  about that often time  [Music]  we're at the premiere tonight of the  reboot but the original cast from Mighty  Morphin Power Rangers are here tonight  reuniting in the same room for the first  time in nearly 25 years  [Music]  [Applause]  me and David Yost are like best friends  and then I talked to JD applause and but  I have a cancer extending forever  kind of incredible incredibly flattering  and nervous for them and hopeful for the  very best when I really think about 25  years is past it's like wow wow and it's  crazy right and like we still wit  whenever we're together we just pick up  where we left yes I mean the chemistry  the family school is still there  [Music]  you